[Music]
quick little background I'm from
academia so I'm actually targeting
students wanting to run Jupiter for my
class and we're gonna go over the the
underlying architecture first the
underlying architecture is that we've
got multiple that we start with with
ipython is the the what we the kernel is
involving in the classic jupiter case
and ipython actually can have multiple
clients and multiple engines and it
coordinate as a controller that
coordinates them and so you can have a
command line a GUI camera web server
proxying for a browser whatever and when
we're actually using Jupiter that kernel
the thing in the way back corner is is
the the typically the the ipython
component there but Jupiter itself is
language agnostic it doesn't have to be
a Jew for a Python kernel in there the
kernel does the code evaluation the the
server shuffles the data back and forth
between the browser the browser is
providing the interface to thanks but
the files that were processing are all
on the server side of the picture
in the students it's all the same
machine so that does simplify things a
tad bit but in general we wanna be I
have to work with the server and the
kernel on different machines even though
they're on the same machine in the case
with my students
well the server is probably on a virtual
machine of some sort they're not things
aren't perfectly well integrated between
the two the two sides of things
the complicated part often seems to be
getting the the data to the server side
and well accessible to the client-side I
was I never crossed my mind but I guess
in the real world you sometimes don't
want your client-side to have access to
the data it's not the world I live in
but yeah that's I was just listening to
people worrying about that this morning
so the overall picture is the browser is
running on the client side I've got a
docker container that has a web server
image and the web server talks to the
language Carl and so I fire up a docker
container and feed it data that I could
also for my students we have to be able
to get to the the data also from the
client side we're not covering here the
scenario where I have this running on a
server somebody else's machine off-site
or not on the user's local machine where
we're trying to well some care if it's a
local maybe if they if we want to have
one machine that we're serving lots of
different projects and people there's
the Jupiter itself doesn't have a any
sort of authentication system in in
Jupiter notebook you have to have a
super hub provide that kind of thing
that's a separate deal I'm we're not
going there today
[Music]
so the example system that I'm working
on the laptop here is what I used to eat
with we've got Windows 10 with well not
Windows 10 home there's my my students
problems they all have Windows 10 home
so they can't run hyper-v so we're good
news this is I can give them the
Microsoft and all state have a nice
little simple
don't let me give the right to my
students to use that but then the the
docker runs on my desktop starts a Linux
VM and typically that does all fires up
with my laptop boots and then when I
issue a command to start up a docker
container docker container is actually
running on that that Linux VM and I have
to use PowerShell to interact with
docker that's going away soon in sense
that the the the next version of docker
on one of the next iterations of Windows
releases will have a better windows subs
or a Windows subsidence for Linux which
is I'm not using right now but under the
newer version of things that will
integrate better basic the basic command
line is I'm going to fire up this really
ugly long command line the inside
PowerShell and the idea is that I'm
going to run an image the image is the
last thing that gets littlest that's
listed but - - RM says I'm going to fire
up this new image and not make changes
to it I don't want the changes to
persist because then the image gets
messed up every time I have a do
something yeah I make mistakes and then
I have to specify the port mapping
between the container and the the host
on which the container is running in my
case localhost and then a mapping
between the the local filesystem dollar
sign home slash work is a directory on
my on my machine well on localhost and
and then the name inside is a filesystem
of the container and I'm basing my my
work on stuff that the Jupiter word
people put out and they had their
username
in their doctor to doctor containers as
Jovian and and I think I misspelled that
Jovian keep done being I've dyslexia
issues I keep on getting through things
swap their so we start up a container
start a browser copy a URL around and
then type an ugly mess in the browser I
was told to be careful with live demos
will give a quick try cuz I've got this
set up and all I have to do is share my
screen with you instead of share that
extra separate screen will give us a
world
so in in powershell i fire up the the
command that we we should we showed
earlier type it and it fires up the
container and the container starts
running and doing its thing and then the
browser side I had to
well localhost yeah all that this really
long token string that's how the
authentication is managed when the
container starts up it fires up a unique
token and I have to authenticate against
my own docker can hear that I'm running
locally oh well if you're actually
running in a multi-user environment that
can be handy I suppose it just seems a
little awkward right now but and then
the thing that's interesting from my
point of view is that typically when you
fire up Jupiter and start up a new
notebook you get your choice of what
kind of notebook as Python 3 or python 2
if you're lucky you have that much
choice and I'm have a one for wide
variety of choices here because that's
what I teach I teach programming
languages so I want to in Jupiter
environment use that to teach a wider
variety of programming languages point
is in order to make that happen I had to
roll my own because asking students to
put this stuff together it would never
work
all sorts of fun when I tell them you
know here's the detailed instructions
just download this and install it on
your machine and let's use that half of
them will still decide to download
something else because they couldn't
follow the directions and then the other
half will decide they knew better and
they have a better way to install phones
a piece of software and then they
install I find I wasn't teaching Swift
and yeah they decided to download
and ice the Apple version of switch
flipped instead of the Linux version of
Swift and it didn't it didn't they
everything that worked on their machine
didn't work on my machine which means
they all failed their homework and they
were upset okay so that the process is
is is a bit awkward to get things going
but once you got things going things
things work reasonably smooth until well
okay I was just a few minutes ago firing
it up and then it didn't work quite the
way I wanted to I shut it down by
hitting ctrl C in the PowerShell
environment and the dock the container
is still running it so it didn't when I
tried to then fire up another instance
there was they were all trying to listen
on the same porch that's no good tried
to kill off one continuum for a good
start the next container anyway and so
there was some maintenance of the the
images I had to list the container
killed the container that was running in
the back that was still running at the
same sort of issues when you have when
you're developing lots of docker images
you end up with docker images that you
would like to get rid of and you have to
so you just learned how to maintain a
docker system a little bit to actually
get the docker image going you I use a
command that looks something like this
I've thrown into it well this is what
gets run I have a script that makes that
I don't have to type all that and does
things like insert the current date so I
have the tag of the image that I'm
building is is always current date and
I have a username and because eventually
I'm going to stick the image into a
docker registry and a half a user name
on the docker registry I use the public
docker registry run by docker toss it
there and then my students can download
it and it's silly we throw gigabytes
back and forth and it all goes we're
ridiculously fast but so we're not gonna
talk right now about how to build the
image we'll get there but then once I
have it an image built locally I push it
off to the to the registry and then have
my students pull it back down
actually I push it back I don't actually
run I'd build the images on on this
machine I have a separate machine that I
do that so I make sure I'm replicating
the student experience that my users
experience that they have to I see I see
what they're going to see instead of
seeing something different
again the point a lot of the points of
this is if we're running things inside a
container and we're all pulling from
that same container and running things
in that same environment I'm never going
to get the it worked on my machine and
it didn't work on yours and and
sometimes it's me saying that it didn't
work on yours and sometimes it's a
student saying you know something works
for them and didn't work for me we we
want to all be using the same exact set
of stuff and the only way I know to get
the exact same set of stuff is to
package it in something like a docker
container or a virtual machine or
whatever I've played with virtual
machines in the past and and instead of
a docker containers but sort of to
compute the comparison about how all
that how virtual machines versus docker
containers work if we're not familiar
with that sort of thing and there's a
first machines coming in in two flavors
a a type 2 and a type 1 so I've got a
type 2 we have an the operating system
kernel runs on the
we're and a hypervisor runs on the
kernel and gust OS is run on top of the
hypervisor so my software application is
one two three four layers away from the
hardware examples of that sort of saying
Oracle VirtualBox VM ware parallels on a
Mac those are all fairly common I each
to use VirtualBox alternatively you can
use a hypervisor in which case your well
your application is one to three layers
because now the hypervisor is on top of
the hardware instead of an operating
system kernel and your guest OS is sit
directly on top of the hypervisor
instead examples that sort of thing
Linux KVM Windows hyper-v does get
things one notch closer to the the
hardware than we were with the type 2
hypervisor containers are well now I'm
I'm one notch closer yet to the hardware
and my application software is going to
run in a namespace inside my operating
system kernel and I have another
namespace and a container is simply a
not the default namespace for everything
but my my application runs on top of the
the kernel the same I'm running a here
I'm sort of it's a hybrid environment
because I'm running docker on top of
hyper-v and wait this pretty but on my
development machine it's pure Linux and
this is exactly what it looks like on
the development side and so the the
containers running in this in a separate
namespace but it's on the same kernel as
everything else
nice close to the hardware there's not a
lot of performance getting in the way
performance issues so yeah here's the
the picture of reality and with what I'm
having doing on this machine is I've got
I do have a an OS kernel fitting that is
fired up by docker which is sits on top
of hyper-v and well the picture shows
the point of the pictures really here
showing that by once I have hyper-v
running once I've installed hyper-v I
know my machine everything is running at
the same layer this is my applications
in my container are no closer are no
further away from the hardware than
anything else I'm doing okay if you
really don't like running things inside
docker you could just run things in it
straight on top of a nun bun tube or
whatever installation on top of of
hyper-v that works fine too I can I
could just as easily I suppose hand my
students a hyper-v image as a docker
image well that's why I'm doing it this
way it's it's not then they have to have
to also figure out how to use a moon too
and I'm not I teach something else it's
a good thing you learn but of course so
when I'm building these images to share
with people I start with images that are
built by Jupiter org and put on github
and again the approach here is to is to
make things avoid this whole it worked
on my machine and doesn't work somewhere
else example and so we start with images
provided at this
github repository and the what we're
building is an image well an image it
ends up being essentially a virtual file
system and it's well it's a set there
called the set of layers layer a layer
is really just a root of a directory and
an image an image looks in the top layer
and it finds the file there great if it
doesn't find the file it looks in the
next layer further down doesn't find it
there look for the next further layer
down on a diffident volume and typically
we're talking about things that have you
know 20 30 layers by the time we're done
building something interesting and again
the the Jupiter project build things on
top of Anna bunch of image and uses the
Anaconda distribution of well not just
Python but there's lots of fun stuff
that they they provide and what anaconda
then provides is package management of
binaries as opposed to source so we
don't have to compile everything from
scratch there's again but we're getting
binaries from somebody we presumably
trust and so in a docker file when we're
building this this is the the language
that we're using we specify an image and
then every time we run a command
something like run it's going to build
another layer in the image and so and
it's assuming that every time we run
things it's going to produce the exact
same result as if we ran it to bran that
expand command on top of the same prior
layer so if
edit my dockerfile and I rebuild it's
gonna look at what we built last time
and say well you ran this exact command
you didn't edit this line so it will
just use what it built last time and not
rebuild a new layer
it essentially caches the results so if
it'll go up to the line that I've made
the change and and then start building
something new and different another set
of layers on top of existing layers and
in the end it does something like expose
some entry point and kini is not teeny
as in tiny it's an it spelled backwards
it that's an in a UNIX system in it is
the first thing the kernel will run once
the kernel gets done booting it starts
things up by running in it which runs
all the stuff in user land and this sets
things up so that a particular shell
script runs and then the last thing I do
is well I copy something in from the
directory that the docker file lives in
into my image that I'm building and as
soon as I use as soon as I use a copy
command it destroys it invalidates by
cache so I do that last if I did that
earlier it would have invalidated the
cache does it assumes that the stuff
inside the container is is not changing
but it assumes everything outside the
container is subject to change so I'm
copying something from the outside in it
invalidates the the caching property and
then it the last thing that this is the
it happens to be the docker file from
Jupiter's minimal notebook or base
notebook I guess this is base notebook
and then that's these are back to not
not root because I'm not crazy with
security I don't run things with root
privileges inside containers
some people are a little less cautious
I'm a little more paranoid but the basic
pattern is we're gonna start with some
bass in egde use the package manager to
install some packages download some
stuff perhaps and then run things like
Conda and pip two pulls think well kind
of pulling strings from anaconda hip
things to compile from source of things
that are not available in in a context
of things are from the Python libraries
are a little larger set than the things
that are available from anaconda so we
install some packages and then we and
then we we run a few things and that
builds the image and then we're ready to
go the server there's a hierarchy that
that docker puts together I'm assuming
that Jupiter org puts together it has
this docker stacks higher project in its
github account and so they start
building things on top of it a bunch of
distribution they have a base notebook
which installs well installs Jupiter
itself but not much in a way of just a
the absolute bare bones number of
packages to get Jupiter off the ground
minimal is as it minimally useful you
can do some interesting things with
minimal notebook and then I build things
on top of a minimal notebook I've been
thinking maybe I should it should go one
not sure true doctors further down on on
their hierarchy and build things on top
of that because every time you forgot
org fixes something it tends to break
something I've done and if I use
presumably when they fix things they'll
have fixed it in the down
versions as well and if I build on
something a little higher level maybe
I'll break less often but that's the the
basic idea then hand that off to my
students and tell them to do stuff and
it I get mixed results
but the mixed results I'm getting are
not of how do I use this tool that was
always the for the fun thing before I
give them some IDE for some set of
languages they would always have
questions about how to use the tool how
to use the IDE I want to answer
questions about how to use the language
not the tool not not the IDE with
Jupiter I'm not getting those questions
that makes me happy questions yeah we
have questions extras a question up on
the screen if you want to go off so what
did you put her greeted doing give some
sampling of why you would want this tool
and set up okay so Jupiter but let's
give it a quick look at what drooper
actually does then that was what we had
I left it running in the background
there somewhere I just gotta go
so once what Jupiter does for us is it
mixes code in markdown with a chunk of
code in whatever language were working
here this one happens to be in Python
and here I'm trying to I am and so the
whole thing is visible in as an HTML
page and it saves the state of things so
I've been actually running Kodi I just
fired it up no code has run but
remembers what I was looking at what it
was displaying last time I ran it so
when I ran the notebook
I ran each of these chunks of code it
produced output and it's saving not just
the the code but the output so there's
three kinds of things I'm looking at I'm
looking at things in markdown which are
essentially documentation chunk of code
that got run and then output and in this
particular case I'm looking at rendering
a graph and again the point is that we
can render things we can display things
that are more interesting than just
plain text no one wants to see things
running in a dumb terminal anymore
and so I have things the default system
is able to display well
HTML and and and SVG and stuff like that
so the graph got the graphite using code
that generates graph in SV graphs an SVG
format and then we just display I don't
have to look at the underlying ugly
stuff but the that set of that's a nice
way to present to somebody where they
can see exactly without having to run my
code exactly what my output was but then
if they have
Jupiter I can if I can have this
displayed to them in a non executable
format there's a notebook browser
there's lesson with them view things or
I can have they can fiddle with it and
run it we're gonna say what if you had
done this instead of that and then push
the button and say you know what if I
had done looked at this as HTML instead
and okay let's run that rerun that and
okay whatever you can you can play the
what-if scenarios see what's going to
happen and and not have to rerun
everything from scratch which when
you're loading in piles of data you
don't want to have to rerun the program
from scratch every time yeah I have a
couple of comments my name is Gregor I'm
from my extensive education and the
first comment no no the first I I
support any university an entire
universe the first comment I actually
have is from our experience we have the
same experience that you have that the
students cannot sometimes type and even
the documentation documented command
that you put into your manual for this
reason we have actually written a tool
that's called CMD 5 which is an
extension to the CMD tool in Python that
uses doc opts which is an I Triple E for
more specification so that you can
instantiate your docker containers with
commands such as start Jupiter sure and
I would think that would be beneficial
the second common distances I'm actually
a part of the no.1 generation I actually
love command lines because it's easy and
the thing that we found is is when we
teach the our students should be two
notebooks they can no longer do
object-oriented programming so any
program that I have to do
the students are coming from the
undergraduate projects or departments
and I ask them to write actually an
object-oriented programming code they no
longer know how to actually use a Python
IDE because that's not anymore taught
because we are using all these stupid on
notebooks and I don't know any object
oriented programming anymore so they can
only develop programs that are three
hundred lines of code using functions so
I would caution the X the overuse of
Jupiter in the education frame other
thing is this is resolved in in this
year's class we actually did something
interesting because we just went to
Google and used Google cool app for
exactly what you just display and
removed the deployment issue that we see
on students that use for example Windows
Home Edition so they can use for many of
the activities and when it's getting
more complicated with and then advise
them to yeah we're on the same page I
wouldn't be doing this in an
introductory level course this is done
in an in a programming language of
course where I'm trying to show them
eight different languages and we're
never going to get in that course to
writing big programs all we're showing
them is a little bit of this a little
bit of that and we never get too big
anything in that kind of course you're
gonna do things where you're doing
non-trivial
programming you want a real live IDE yep
question do you feel like there's an
advantage to having them run docker and
Dupree notebooks locally on their own
computer versus using a cloud service
like Python anywhere or the Google
collab or Microsoft has Microsoft
notebooks now when we started working
doing this I would didn't
wasn't aware of how many were out there
and the ones that I was seeing without
were out there I was having problems
getting them to share filesystem with me
I'd have to it was getting awkward to
move data back and forth and again they
had a very limited number of go Google
lab I get frustrated with because it has
a very limited number of packages at
least maybe not a limit it has a lot of
them but not the ones I want and there
are other ones where you can build
essentially hand them a docker container
a docker file and have them build on
their side and then run on their side
and that would certainly be be doable
I thought anyone gives you kind of a
standard set the Microsoft notebooks you
can put a requirements file in there and
it'll just install into the notebook of
the things you need again if you're
running this is a Python conference so
you all you care about is by title of
course but but yes that would be good
for you not good for me because I'm
trying to six other languages seven
other language tolerate
Python is one of them and and my
students are always shocked that you can
actually do object-oriented program in
Python because they were taught Python
in freshman but not oriented
[Music]